absolutely not this is fine
as guardian leather hang on just a
minute
hello friends carlos bustamante here
perhaps the most highly anticipated of
the marvel disney plus series has
arrived
loki made its debut today so of course
we want to talk about it now
in this video we're mainly going to be
covering the tva and what they mean for
the multiverse
but of course that means talking some
show details so as always
spoilers ahead this is et cannons
no matter the timeline it seems like
everyone's favorite norse god of
mischief can't quite catch a break
after escaping with the tesseract any
further plans loki may have had
are thwarted in the first episode of
loki's solo series
by the mysterious group calling
themselves the tva
the time-variance authority
what is this place they are as the show
states the keepers of the sacred
timeline
it's their duty to make sure they squash
what the big bosses the timekeepers
deem deviations from that ultimate plan
we're not here to talk about the
avengers
oh no no what they did was supposed to
happen you
escaping was not according to this
series
everything that's ever happened on the
timeline good or bad
was supposed to happen so the avengers
seemingly wreaking havoc on the timeline
and avengers and game
all part of the plan things that aren't
like loki's theft of the tesseract and
attempted escape
are variances that need to be corrected
and thus loki variant l1130 becomes
the star of the show infinity stones
[Applause]
how do you have these oh we actually got
a lot of those
yeah some of the guys use them as paper
weights
some of them but as supporting players
how much will the tva factor into the
mcu moving forward
and will their existence here be the key
to finally busting open the door to
marvel's multiverse
as usual the comics are a great place to
look to give us some clues
in those stories the tv serves much the
same purpose as outlined in the show
except there
instead of policing one sacred timeline
they overlook the entire multiverse and
just
try to keep time shenanigans to a
minimum which you can imagine
it's pretty difficult over the decades
the tva has had dealings with marvel's
big three super teams the avengers the
x-men
and the fantastic four as well as big
bads like kang the conqueror
all this sets up some very intriguing
possibilities regarding what characters
could make special appearances on the
show and how it may be setting up the
new multiversal mcu
we've all been talking about for a while
now kang is an
important link here as the time
traveling reality hopping villain was
romantically linked
to the comic book version of ravana
renslayer played in the show by gugu and
batara
it's easy to imagine that if kang is
involved with the tva
somehow in this show it could lead to
his villainous turn in the upcoming
ant-man and the wasp
quantomania gugu has said recently that
she sees this
as a sort of origin story for ravana
with the events of loki taking place
before anything in the comics
could it serve as kang's mcu origin
story as well
[Music]
don't worry that devil's afraid of us
we're gonna take care of them
while it's proven to be dangerous to put
too much hope into a theory like that
mephisto like the multiverse itself
the possibilities are seemingly endless
so let's talk about it in the comments
below
i'd love to read your takes on where
this series might go and what you would
love to see come out of loki's
multiversal medley see you next time
you